is the new iPhone 15 worth it over the
iPhone 14 well in this video we're gonna
go all out and compare everything
between these two including the designs
displays cameras speakers performance
and much more alright let's get this
thing out of the box and to my first
impressions what wait a second is that
the actual back or is there like film on
there holy moly wow yeah oh my goodness
that looks so weird
um okay so this is Matt finally has the
matte back glass look at how glossy it
is on the red iPhone I hated how much
fingerprints get on it but this thing
finally fingerprint resistant but the
cool thing is the actual logo and the
camera is still glossy so just like we
have on the Pro Models but wow this is
apparently the green model very very
subtle colors and oh Max I know you
tried the pro Max so you know how the
new curved design feels yeah it's nice
but cheese the subtle difference of how
it no longer like digs and hurts when
you dig it into your palm it's smooth
and like super soft this is so much more
pleasant and looking at the camera bumps
they actually look like they're the same
size the only difference I see is that
the glasses actually match on the iPhone
14 but now glossy on the 15 still looks
great especially with a full matte glass
back and the only other difference on
the outside is of course the brand new
USBC port and the really nice bonus this
year is that apple is including a
braided USBC to USBC cable now this one
feels a lot better it's going to be
better at not freeing and getting ripped
like all of those old cables always got
ripped and messed up now this one does
not support higher data transfer speeds
which is perfect for the iPhone 15
because it doesn't support 10 gigabit
per second transfers like the 15 Pro and
now for my favorite part oh there you go
super nice and clean all right getting
into the setup look at that we have a
couple of really big differences first
of all are those bezels thinner Max on
the 15 maybe
I think they are if you look side by
side it's actually thinner of course the
iPhone 15 finally gets rid of that darn
Notch it's gone it looks so much premium
just look at the front so much more
premium and I've been using my 14 pro
Max for a year and it's been so useful
for going into the music app by just
tapping the dynamic Island you can tap
and hold for more settings like
switching the music and it's been useful
for other things like tracking your
flight or keeping an eye on your timers
and wait a minute hold on if I look
super closely yep yep the new iPhone 15
has an earpiece speaker that's literally
three times thinner I can barely see it
right there next to the edge of the
frame whereas the earpiece on the 14 is
massive and speaking of that earpiece
speaker I'm gonna get this set up so we
could test out the speakers
[Applause]
bring me back
[Music]
you guys let me know which one you think
sounds better down in the comments
section below but to me they sound
basically identical I plan them back a
couple of times I'm hearing zero
differences whereas with the 15 pro
model it actually did get louder and it
sounds better than on the 14 pro so it's
sad to see no difference here now what
did change is the display because this
year the iPhone 15 actually got the same
crazy nice and bright display from the
iPhone 14 pro which means it supports up
to a thousand nits of regular brightness
up to 1600 for HDR video and 2 000 when
you're outside alright guys we actually
just tested this outside we tested it in
HDR watching some videos and for some
reason they both kind of look the same
in terms of brightness technically the
new one should be brighter maybe there's
some kind of software glitch where it's
not letting it go all the way or maybe
YouTube's not making it I don't know
this is really odd but uh hopefully it
should be fixed soon now whether you're
upgrading to the iPhone 15 or not you
absolutely need to keep it protected and
the best way to do that is with a case
from our sponsor Rhino Shield offering
endless fully customizable designs and
easy to apply screen protectors for a
360 degree coverage their solid
suitcases are slim while giving you 11
foot drop protection with their
proprietary shock spread Tech and this
year they have improved grip and nine
new colors the mod NX modular case is
unique because you can switch from an
open back bumper case with a raised Edge
for protection or add a swappable back
plate anytime with thousands of
different designs including cool
collaborations and their Max save
magnets are twice as strong as on
Apple's case they've also got their
clear case which is now 23 thinner while
offering the same impact protection and
with a five-year warranty against
yellowing or discoloration they even
have cases for Apple watch and earpods
and even if you're not looking to
upgrade to an iPhone 15 you can still
get a fresh look with new accessories by
using my link in the description and
code Max Tech 10 to get 10 off today and
now let's get into the performance
testing as you guys know the new iPhone
15 has the same a16 bionic chip from
last year's iPhone 14 pro and of course
we have the a15 on the iPhone 14. now
both of them have the same six gigabytes
of RAM only the new 15 pro has got the
upgrade to eight and you can see the
clock speed difference on the a16 3.45
gigahertz compared to 3.23 which should
give us faster single core performance
let's go ahead and run the CPU Benchmark
all right we got the results and this is
very interesting for a couple of reasons
first of all we have a 13 Improvement in
single core and 14 18.5 percent in
multi-core and believe it or not but
that's actually a bigger difference
than the scores that we got with the
17 Pro chip and the iPhone 15 Pro that's
kind of funny we had about 10.7 for a
single core and under 10 for multi-core
but in reality these scores aren't
really going to change much for your
everyday usage or experience with both
of these phones now even though the a17
pro isn't as fast it actually does have
Ray tracing metal effects upscaling
support for gaming so that's actually
going to be useful but both of these
there's not really much difference so
let's get into the Metal Graphics test
and here we have the Metal Graphics
scores and wow that is a tiny tiny
difference that's only six percent
faster for the iPhone 15 and if you
didn't know already the GPU is literally
identical the same five core GPU you can
watch the geeker one video he shows off
the die shots there's just some sort of
improvement Apple did so geekbench is a
little bit faster but let's actually Run
3D marks Wildlife extreme unlimited test
to see the difference there what the
heck are you guys seriously look at this
score it's done only 3.8 percent faster
for the a16 chip and the iPhone 15. that
is absolutely insane yeah it has
basically the same GPU so with this in
mind do not upgrade for that a16 chip it
doesn't matter just consider them
basically the same and upgrade for other
reasons like the cameras so let's go
ahead and get into the camera comparison
the first thing I want to start off with
is this selfies now they both have
basically the same 12 megapixel sensor
so no difference is in actual Hardware
but you guys can see that there's this
little F logo right there on the iPhone
15 that doesn't show up now keep in mind
we have the same software on both iOS
17. if I click this it switches to a
portrait mode photo which is really cool
because it's detecting my face however
if I take a selfie like this I can
actually go into the edit menu hit the
portrait button and actually convert the
regular photo into a portrait which you
do not have that option on the iPhone 14
and you can even change the portrait
Focus the point of focus on the iPhone
15 but actually looking up close for
some reason the iPhone 14
looks better maybe it was just slightly
better focus now moving over to the back
we have the same camera layout diagonal
like this with two cameras including the
ultra wide which has not changed at all
it's still 12 megapixel on the iPhone 15
but we do have a major absolutely major
difference for the main camera which is
the new 48 megapixel sensor now it's not
as big as the 48 megapixel on the 15 Pro
but it is still very very good it allows
you to shoot at 48 megapixel resolution
with the heif max mode but by far the
biggest deal is that it now defaults to
24 megapixel resolution photos two times
more than we've had for so many years
which means basically everything is
going to look more sharp now especially
the portraits and basically everything
else you take with the main camera but
now my absolute favorite part with the
iPhone 15 is that Apple finally added a
2X crop button but the problem with
digitally zooming in from further away
to get a 2X shot is that it actually
ruins the quality so take a look this is
the 14 digitally zooming from one to two
but with the new 2x button look at that
on the iPhone 15 so much more quality
look at the hair everything a lot more
better quality because it's actually
cropping from the 48 megapixel sensor
into half of the sensor for the 2x crop
leading to excellent quality and on top
of that when you're cropping in after
the fact you're not taking advantage of
Apple's camera pipeline where it's
optimizing the image like here and
another issue with the 1X lens is that
when you want to get closer to a subject
you actually have Distortion in the face
as you can see right here you can see
that like the nose is bigger and it
doesn't look as good as this which has a
more natural further zoom and to prove
my point here is one where I got really
close to Max's face and you can just see
the difference right here this looks
like a really good shot with really nice
focal length whereas this is just
inflating the whole front of his face it
just looks bad so the fact that they
have a 2X is a huge deal now getting
into the actual Zoom shots the previous
iPhone 14 can only go up to 5x Zoom
which the new one can as well you can
see a huge
quality difference with the iPhone 15
but even better you can also zoom up to
10x right there and just to show you
guys how big of a deal the new 24
megapixel default camera mode is you can
see I zoomed in on the 12 megapixel of
the 14 and here is the 24 megapixel you
get a lot more detail look at all those
trees and bushes tons of detail with 24
but then finally you can go even further
with a 48 megapixel heif photo which
takes it to a whole new level of detail
apple is not messing around and they're
really given the iPhone 15 a killer
camera so now that I've actually pixel
peeped into those photos I would say
that this is the biggest camera update
to the regular iPhones ever that 24
megapixel mode and everything else is
just a huge deal for every day photos
and and on top of that you have the
dynamic Island you have the USBC Port
you have the matte glass the curved
design so many upgrades with the iPhone
15. honestly I'd say that this is
probably a bigger deal than the 15 Pros
so to finish out this video if you're
thinking of buying the iPhone 15 or
maybe saving 100 bucks by going for the
iPhone 14 or maybe 200 savings by going
for the 13 screw those models this is
the one you want to get pay the extra
money because this is a massive upgrade
with everything that I dug into in this
video and honestly if you're thinking
about skipping this upgrade waiting
until the iPhone 16 well if you're a fan
of regular models this is the year to
upgrade because most likely next year
the pros and maybe even the ultra that's
where the upgrades are gonna come every
big upgrade came this year so this is
the one to go for hopefully you enjoy
this video if you did click the circle
to subscribe and check out our 15 Pro
Max comparison versus the older model
right there don't forget to use the code
Max Tech 10 for 10 off your Rhino Shield
case thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
foreign